[Music]
in good nights we can see almost
everything galaxies nebulas the best
thing you can see here is the milky way
it's very bright and you can see a lot
of shooting stars as well
some nights are so good that it's one of
the best places to observe
in the world
and the best part this view comes with a
room up here they take reservations
[Music]
gornergrat is a special place that opens
up the universe to everyone perched on
top of the swiss alps at over ten
thousand feet it's a hotel restaurant
and an observatory
what might seem like an unlikely mix has
turned into one of switzerland's most
precious places
[Music]
the cool motel gonograd was built in
1907.
some parts of the the building are still
the same as in the in the beginning we
have 22 rooms
there are four or five days a year where
there are 5 000 people it's the highest
hotel in switzerland and the second
highest in europe the special thing up
here is is the the mountain you can see
around there is a monte rosa and then
the brighton and everybody in the world
knows the mataron
[Music]
we serve mostly traditional swiss food
cheese fondue
roast with the sausage on it and the
onion sauce and also the alper macaroni
it's really special for me because i
love the mountains up here in the night
it's very calm
and this guy is really amazing
[Music]
these domes are here from the 60s until
now but astronomy here in the mountains
goes back to the beginning of 1900
scientists from all over the world has
been here if you want to do astronomy
you have to have really good conditions
and it's a fact that the best conditions
you have up here in the mountains
lack of light pollution and dry air have
meant that people like jessie can really
observe space from here
but even with the naked eye anyone can
observe the night beauty at gornergrat
it's one of the best places i've been
for sure you go out on the terrace and
you see this huge band over the sky and
it's just so bright it's amazing and
like the stars above gornergratch shines
bright in the middle of the swiss alps
keeping the gateway to space open for
many years to come
you